the media getting slammed again for
trying to equate hamas's Slaughter of
children to Israel's retaliatory strikes
a Washington Post columnist writing this
column quote we cannot stand by and
watch Israel commit atrocities the
writer condemns hamas's attacks as
horrific but also says that America
shouldn't let Israel
retaliate uh that's nuts judge yeah all
right if the mission of Hamas is to
destroy Israel and exterminate Jews and
then Hamas turns around and hides behind
victims so then they're not allowed to
protect themselves so Israel should be
immobilized we should Israel shouldn't
exact Revenge Israel should leave them
in power to pursue their mission to
exterminate the Jews and they should
never feel the consequences of what
they've done they should be allowed to
continue in their mission to kill you
and get another shot at you because they
hide behind a victim no people in
Academia don't have the slightest idea
what they're talking about they've never
been a part of the real hardcore world
and in the end uh that Israel is doing
everything they can to minimize
casualties but they have an obligation
to defend themselves Jesse during the
Trump Administration the media said you
know what there's not two sides you
can't do that it's only right and that's
and then there's evil but on this issue
it's like they're actually publishing an
oped from a pro terrorist sympathizer
that I don't think that was actually
necessary
I would say that um you Israel went out
of their way to distinguish between
Palestinians and Hamas and they gave
them ample opportunity to leave which is
a lot more than Hamas gave the innocent
Israelis that they slaughtered well said
Greg uh what's he going to do about it
he said he's like you can't what's he
going to do about it do something about
it uh they aren't even doing both sides
they're louder about Israel and quieter
about Hamas I wish it was both sides
compared to that anyway I was glad to
see secretary blinkin in Israel today
with the defense minister saying
America's with you and you need not uh
need not we won't Flinch hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now